voici le carton d'invitation qui
convient les maires des outre-mer à une
rencontre avec le président de la
république ce vendredi david zobda fait
partie de la vingtaine de maires de la
martinique qui feront le déplacement
le premier magistrat de la ville du
lamentin envisage d'intervenir sur
quatre points ce sont des points qui ce
qui entrait d'abord sur le premier
d'entre eux à aux finances publiques à
la situation des collectivités
territoriales de martinique à notre
capacité d'investissement sur la
commande publique
le deuxième point sur lesquels je vais
intervenir c'est sur l'université
problématique de l'université met en
lien avec la politique de la jeunesse
troisième point sur lesquels
j'interviendrai c'est celui de la santé
la situation de nos hôpitaux et la
nécessité de la coopération régionale
notamment les cuma et enfin je
reviendrai sur une situation
catastrophique de notre pays
c'est un situation de la pauvreté de la
précarité le maire de l'otraf
montplaisir sera lui aussi du voyage
il entend faire une proposition liée au
pouvoir d'achat
ils militent pour une baisse des prix
par familles de produits de première
nécessité alors l'idée c'est que sur ses
familles de produits des efforts
pourraient être faits par les
transporteurs comme par les
distributeurs de façon à baisser le coût
du produit
le coût du transport ou et la marge du
distributeur
certains maires ont cependant décidé de
ne pas faire le déplacement c'est par
exemple le cas pour les villes de
schoelcher de sainte luce ou encore de
ducos
pour charles andré mancey les solutions
se trouvent d'abord chez nous sa maladie
c'est que problème mardi nuc s'est pas
calmée poignet c'est les martiniquais
mêmes qui ont empêché marking avancé
pour que gekko d'accord pour nous
travaillons sans martinique d'abord la
solution à bord donc l'année de son nez
un message qui passait mais l'accueil
palais de le croire je dis que c'est
qu'elle nous même si les martin coeur
qui profitent des coachings empêcher
même s'ils y vont les maires sont pour
certains dubitatifs
ils attendent encore par exemple les
résultats des assises d outre-mer en
résumé ils craignent que cela ne se
transforme une nouvelle fois en une
grand messe sans actions concrètes